John was who's lonely and he was
depressed he wasn't a monster by any me
you know he was a normal young man who
started getting sick and doesn't get the
right help in time wasn't medicated
mental health was different back then
they didn't understand it as much as we
do now we still don't understand it to
the point where he would want to you
know he suffered primarily from
schizotypal disorder schizotypal
personality disorder can be anything
from a void of emotion or too much
emotion so then it's just kind of
day-to-day you know he suffered from
depression and borderline personality
disorders during that time of struggle
he taxi driver came out and I think he
saw the movie for something 17 to 30
times and you know he had obsessions he
had mental illness so he he began to
really relate with the Travis Bickle
character and he was obsessed with the
Beatles and Bowie and in poetry I mean
he was a hopeless romantic
so I think when he saw that Jodie was
going to Yale you know he he saw her as
a real person that maybe one day he
would meet and then maybe she would fall
for him
and then it just kind of spirals from
there you know the the odds aren't as uh
as big as before you know she's going to
college she's she's normal there's a
chance that if I run into her she could
fall in love with me and then it becomes
it goes from there to I think she
already is in love with me you know so
and that's when the reality and fantasy
start to unravel